violette retourne son auto au
concessionnaire après sa location de
quatre ans quelques semaines plus tard
elle reçoit une facture de 1000 $ en
raison d'égratignures sur une porte et
d'une bosse sur le capot cela est
considéré comme de l'usure excessive
violette est fâché oui quelques cailloux
ont des cahiers la peinture mais cela
est causé par un usage normal dans nos
conditions de conduite au pays et la loi
est claire le concessionnaire ne peut
pas obliger violette rendre l'auto dans
un meilleur état que celui qui résulte
d'une usure normale et dans le contrat
il ne peut pas définir lui même ce qui
est l'usure normale
seul un tribunal peut juger que
l'automobile présente une mesure
excessive à la violette vue constaté les
dommages elle-même mais trop tard le
concessionnaire n'a plus le taux en sa
possession les seules options qui lui
reste son de contester ou de demander à
un tribunal de trancher si elle avait su
elle aurait pris des photos mieux encore
elle aurait fait inspecter elle même le
véhicule avant de le remettre le fameux
l'histoire pour échapper aux
concessionnaires excessif
soyez proactif
[Musique]